[Musica]
come avete scelto sino ad ora il museo
da visitare
dalla nascita del cosiddetto web 2.0 da
quando cioè tutto viene condiviso e
soprattutto commentato online si è
capito che non era più possibile non
tener conto del parere degli utenti e
questa consapevolezza è entrata oggi
anche nel rapporto fra musei e
visitatori siamo in un mondo che sta
cambiando molto velocemente e se vediamo
i dati pubblicati da william social
scopriamo che 37 milioni e mezzo di
italiani sono attivi sul web 28 milioni
sono attivi sui social media
ma il dato che ci interessa di più è
quello che ci dice che 10 milioni di
utenti entrano in contatto con i musei
proprio attraverso le piattaforme social
tra le piattaforme social che vengono
utilizzate per questo contatto c'è anche
tripadvisor tripadvisor lo sapete è una
piattaforma che nasce per recensire
sotto e ricettive ma oggi ha concentrato
la sua attenzione anche sulle attrazioni
turistiche e in questa sezione sono
compresi anche i musei ma è possibile
che una persona decida di visitare un
museo solo perché l'ha letto su
tripadvisor
a quanto pare la risposta a questa
domanda è affermativa visto che proprio
se ci basiamo sui commenti e che
troviamo sulla piattaforma spesso
leggiamo ho deciso di visitare il tal
dei tali perché ho letto delle ottime
recensioni su tripadvisor e di fatto
anche la mia ricerca è nata dall aver
incontrato persone che usavano
tripadvisor per pianificare le proprie
visite e il proprio programma di viaggio
era il 2013
ero in coda ai musei vaticani e parlando
con un gruppo di persone queste mi
dissero che quel giorno avrebbero visto
i musei vaticani e il giorno dopo
sarebbero andati ai musei capitolini
proprio perché l'avevano letto sulla
piattaforma
ovviamente la cosa mi incuriosì molto
ed è tornato a casa mi fiondai al
computer questo è il mio lato curioso e
per andare a vedere che cosa le persone
dicevano dei musei italiani e mi sono
trovata davanti una vera e propria
miniera di dati e ne ho capito subito la
potenzialità se quei dati venivano
correttamente valutati e filtrati si
potevano ottenere una serie di
informazioni molto interessanti e dunque
ho deciso di cominciare a lavorare
leggendo le recensioni sui musei romani
i musei romani perché sono quelli che io
conosco meglio sono quelli su cui ho
lavorato negli anni e su cui già avevo
pubblicato un lavoro sulla comunicazione
multimediale e fra i musei romani scelsi
quelli che superavano le 100 recensioni
per avere un numero abbastanza
consistente di dati da da analizzare
alla fine sapete quante recensioni ho
letto su un partita pian piano sono
arrivata a leggere nel per l'esattezza
14.000 936 recensioni quando uno si
vuole bene ed è determinata ho iniziato
creando una tabella nella tabella
inserivo tutti i dati che emergevano
dalla lettura dei commenti
poi però essendo i commenti liberi e
soggettivi dovevo trovare un modo per
poterli comparare questi dati e quindi
ho deciso di semplificarvi la vita e da
una tabella sono passata a 6 tabelle
però però queste sei tabelle avevano uno
scopo
avevo individuato tre macro aree molto
importanti per il museo in cui andare a
valutare i dati la prima dedicata al
museo inteso nel suo senso più generale
riguarda per esempio l'orientamento
nelle sale il comfort ambientale
l'illuminazione la presenza o meno di
aree di sosta
il secondo marca macro argomento
fondamentale dedicato ai sussidi alla
visita quindi a tutti quei supporti che
servono ai visitatori per poter
comprendere
le opere e il contesto di riferimento e
quindi didascalie pannelli didattici
audioguide sistemi multimediali
infine il terzo ma caso momento è
dedicato ai cosiddetti servizi
aggiuntivi bookshop caffetteria bagni
guardaroba
ho deciso poi di introdurre un'ulteriore
distinzione fra le recensioni dei
visitatori italiani e le recensioni dei
visitatori stranieri perché mi è parso
subito chiaro dalla lettura dei primi
commenti che c'era una diversa
percezione delle nostre situazioni
museali
se gli italiani sono molto soddisfatti e
dando giudizi molto alti sui nostri
musei perché riconoscono i capolavori
che vi sono conservati per formazione
scolastica esperienza personale
gli stranieri che fanno più difficoltà a
comprendere le nostre opere e
soprattutto il contesto storico
artistico italiano di riferimento
tendo non essere molto più critici
sull'istituzione museo
questo anche perché soprattutto se
provenienti dall america
dall'inghilterra diciamo che sono
abituati a musei molto grandi molto
organizzati molto efficienti e ricchi di
servizi destinati ai pubblici ma
facciamo un esempio pratico sulla
differenza di percezione fra gli
italiani e gli americani
una delle prime attrazioni una delle
cosiddette attrazioni più visitate fra
le più visitate a roma sono le domus
romane di palazzo valentini
se cercate su tripadvisor compagne
sempre come privo come secondo le domus
sono state musealizzate c'è un percorso
prestabilito delle proiezioni video
sulle pareti e la voce narrante di piero
angela accompagnano il visitatore
dall'inizio alla fine della visita
se si leggono i commenti dei visitatori
italiani si legge che la visita è
considerata emozionante e accattivante
queste sono le due parole che ricorrono
più frequentemente nei commenti degli
italiani perché perché la si milano ad
un programma televisivo e molti citano
superquark come paragone
se andiamo a leggere di contro le
recensioni degli americani scopriamo che
si dicono delusi perché assimilano la
visita ad un programma televisivo
discovery channel
e allora molti dicono se dovevo venire a
roma per guardare un documentario di
discovery channel
allora preferivo starmene a casa mia
sdraiato sul mio divano qui capite che
la differenza di aspettative e le
differenze di abitudini e le tre dei
musei causano giudizi più o meno
positivi sulle istituzioni
ma quali sono le critiche che emergono
più frequentemente all'interno dei
commenti
beh per esempio il problema dei book
shop che chiudono prima della fine
dell'ultimo turno di visita non
consentendo agli ultimi visitatori di
comprare neanche una cartolina una
matita non dico la guida che magari
troppo costosa un segnalibro e questo
capirete che anche dal punto di vista
del marketing
non è proprio una bella pensata e ma poi
abbiamo anche per esempio il problema
della mancanza di sedute davanti alle
opere che permettano brevi soste
contemplativo anche un pochino più
lunghe oppure la mancanza di punti in
cui poter ricaricare gli smartphone
soprattutto là dove magari al museo si
richiede di scaricare un'app per fruire
meglio della visita e delle opere
o ancora per quanto riguarda per esempio
i supporti alla visita i sussidi alla
visita grave mancanza è quella delle
mappe è difficilissimo orientarsi
all'interno del museo
non ditemi che voi non vi siete mai
persi in un museo io lo ammetto mi sono
persa due anni fa al victoria and albert
di londra e non è stato bellissimo poi
tutta la mappa mi sono persa per altro
ma va bene di solito però la mancanza di
mappe della mappa è un problema grave e
poi abbiamo il problema delle didascalie
che sono mai tradotte in inglese o sono
poco comprensibili perché scritte in un
linguaggio troppo tecnico perché
cancellate dal tempo perché scritte in
trasparenza in una vetrina trasparente e
magari illuminata
oppure perché messe in posizione che
richiedono una certa necessità da parte
del visitatore
ma cosa ci serve sapere tutto questo
conoscere quello che pensano i nostri
musei ci aiuta ad avere un'indicazione
della soddisfazione del visitatore è un
indicatore fondamentale il museo se
leggesse questi commenti potrebbe trarne
idee suggerimenti per migliorare
l'offerta comunicativa potrebbe anche
decidere per esempio di valutare
l'efficacia delle politiche comunicative
che mette in atto ad esempio io museo
introduco l'audioguida e vedo nel tempo
attraverso la lettura dei commenti se
questa cosa e apprezzato o meno oppure
se la posso migliorare questi sono dati
utilissimi che noi possiamo
tranquillamente mettere a confronto con
i dati che emergono dai questionari sui
pubblici di cui molti musei oggi già
dispongono ultimamente solo ultimamente
sono tantissimo passati tre anni da
quando ho cominciato la mia ricerca si è
capito quanto sono importanti i commenti
che vengono
rilasciati online lo ha capito
tripadvisor che periodicamente pubblica
la graduatoria dei musei più graditi dal
pubblico
leggete spessissimo ormai compaiono sui
quotidiani più o meno una volta al mese
proprio basandosi compirà alla
graduatoria proprio basandosi sui
commenti dei propri contributori è stato
poi sviluppato un algoritmo è dedicato
all'analisi dei feedback che vengono
rilasciati sui social media in merito ai
nostri musei è fondamentale conoscere il
sentiment dei visitatori
perché solo così riusciamo a capire
quali sono le reali necessità delle
persone che vengono a visitare i nostri
musei e solo così possiamo adottare le
politiche adeguate per comunicare meglio
con loro tenendo sempre conto che non
esiste il visitatore ideale ma esiste
piuttosto un pubblico differenziato per
età cultura competenze informatiche
formazione personale e anche impiego del
proprio tempo di visita c'è chi sceglie
di ciechi a mezz'ora perché magari è di
passaggio ma vuole vedere un'opera e c'è
chi ha tre ore 5 ore perché magari è in
vacanza un perché magari è una persona
interessata per cui dobbiamo 3 mettere
in conto tutte queste cose e allora in
un era ormai largamente tecnologica e in
cui la tecnologia entrata ampiamente
anche nei nostri musei e lo vedete
sempre più spesso noi entriamo al museo
e possiamo trovare up tavoli thatcher
totem adesso anche visore di realtà
aumentata
e allora la vera rivoluzione in realtà è
quella di far diventare i nostri musei
sempre più partecipati e accoglienti
rimettendo il visitatore al centro del
museo e ora come sceglierete prossimo
museo da visitare
[Applauso]